en el vídeo pasado vimos desplazamientos
de hidrógenos y de grupos metidos ahora
en este vídeo
vamos a ver reordenamientos de carbó
cationes también conocidos como
transposiciones de carbó cationes así es
que vamos a empezar con éste carbó
catión este carbono tiene una carga
formal positiva y está enlazado con
otros dos carbonos por lo que este es un
carbó catión secundario podemos ponernos
a pensar en que se puede desplazar en
esta molécula por ejemplo podemos pensar
en los dos hidrógenos que tiene este
carbono en el primer caso que vamos a
observar lo que sucede es que uno de
estos hidrógenos se desplaza a éste
carbó catión si es que tomamos este
hidrógeno y los electrones de este
enlace y lo movemos hacia este car
'vocación dibujemos que es lo que nos
queda primero tenemos aquí este anillo
de carbonos que tiene un grupo metilo
por acá y además sabemos que éste carbó
catión desde el principio
tiene un hidrógeno este carbón ya tenía
un hidrógeno pero ahora él y duro se
desplazó a éste carbó catión y entonces
se encuentra por acá este carbono que
estoy coloreando de verde ahora
únicamente tiene un hidrógeno este
carbono tiene un hidrógeno ok la
acabamos de quitar un enlace a este
carbono por lo que tiene una carga
formal positiva tiene una carga formal
positiva pero bueno seguimos teniendo un
carbó catión secundario porque éste
carbó catión está enlazado con dos
carbonos es un carbó catión secundario
por lo que no está mejorando la
situación por lo que no está haciendo
más estable a esta molécula los dos son
carbó cationes secundarios ahora no lo
tenemos que dibujar de esta forma se
puede dibujar de esta otra por aquí
dibujamos a todos estos hidrógenos para
que quede muy claro pero cuando uno ya
lleva un poco más de práctica puede
dejar de dibujar a los hidrógenos aunque
si estás empezando es una
buena práctica dibujar todos los
hidrógenos bueno ahora pensemos en la
posibilidad de un desplazamiento del
grupo metilo porque pues este
desplazamiento de hidrógeno no nos ayudó
mucho no hizo que el kart vocación fuera
más estable entonces ahora vamos a ver
el desplazamiento de este grupo metilo a
éste carbó catión vamos a dibujar que es
lo que nos quedaría tenemos aquí este
anillo de carbonos y estamos moviendo
este grupo metilo de rojo a éste carbó
catión ok a este carbono pero este
carbono ya estaba enlazado con un
hidrógeno que estamos dibujando por acá
y en este proceso a este carbono de azul
le estamos quitando un enlace por lo que
ahora este es el carbó catión tiene una
carga formal positiva aunque este
carbono también estaba enlazado con un
hidrógeno por aquí tenemos ese hidrógeno
ahora está car vocación que se acaba de
formar
sigue siendo un kart vocación secundario
porque está enlazado con dos carbonos
así es que este es un kart vocación
secundario y otra vez seguimos sin hacer
que la molécula sea más estable y por
supuesto no tenemos que dibujar todos
estos hidrógenos podemos simplemente
dibujar esto aquí en este carbono está
el grupo metilo y este es el carbó
catión con su carga formal positiva
entonces ya vimos estas dos opciones y
cuál es la última opción que nos falta
bueno pues podríamos volver a intentar
un desplazamiento de hidrógeno pero en
lugar de desplazar alguno de estos dos
hidrógenos podríamos ver qué pasa si
desplazamos a este otro hidrógeno vamos
a ver qué pasa si sucede un
desplazamiento de este hidrógeno este
hidrógeno y sus dos electrones de este
enlace se van a mover a éste carbó
catión vamos a dibujar lo que nos queda
tenemos el anillo de carbonos el grupo
metilo se queda donde está pero
el hidrógeno azul se movió para acá
entonces tenemos por aquí el hidrógeno
azul con sus dos electrones que también
se movieron con el hidrógeno y además
este carbono ya estaba enlazado con otro
hidrógeno que estamos dibujando por acá
ahora en este desplazamiento le quitamos
un enlace a este carbono azul por lo que
ahora tiene una carga formal positiva y
ahora observemos qué tan estable es este
kart vocación está enlazado con 1 2 y 3
carbonos así es que es un kart vocación
bastante estable es un kart vocación
terciario y como hemos visto en vídeos
anteriores los carbó cationes terciarios
son más estables que los cars vocaciones
secundarios entonces este es el tipo de
reordenamiento que veríamos que pasa de
un kart vocación secundario a uno
terciario a través del desplazamiento de
un hidrógeno y al igual que en los dos
ejemplos anteriores
no necesitamos dibujar todos los
hidrógenos podemos simplemente dibujar
pero además este tiene una carga formal
positiva y es un kart vocación terciario
más estable que el kart vocación
secundario que teníamos ahora veamos
otro ejemplo de una transposición de
carbó catión este ejemplo va a ser más
sencillo que el anterior así es que aquí
tenemos nuestro carbó catión este
carbono tiene una carga formal positiva
y está enlazado con otros dos carbonos
por lo que es un kart vocación
secundario pensemos en qué tipo de
desplazamientos se pueden dar en esta
molécula por aquí este carbono tiene dos
hidrógenos por lo que podríamos pensar
en un desplazamiento de estos hidrógenos
entonces alguno de estos dos hidrógenos
junto con sus dos electrones del enlace
se pueden desplazar a éste carbó catión
y lo que nos queda es esto que estamos
dibujando tenemos dos grupos metilo por
acá y este hidrógeno rojo se desplazó
para acá este hidrógeno se desplazó a
este carbono pero antes de que sucediera
desplazamiento este carbono ya estaba
enlazado con otro hidrógeno ahora en
este desplazamiento le quitamos un
enlace a este carbono que estoy
coloreando de verde y ahora únicamente
le queda este hidrógeno entonces este
carbono verde ahora sólo tiene un
hidrógeno pero como le quitamos un
enlace ahora tiene una carga formal
positiva entonces el carbono verde ahora
es el carbó catión y está enlazado con
otros dos carbonos por lo que es un kart
vocación secundario pero justo como
sigue siendo un kart vocación secundario
no estamos mejorando la estabilidad de
la molécula por cierto recuerda que esta
molécula también se puede dibujar de
esta forma simplemente no dibujamos
todos estos hidrógenos pero bueno ahora
vamos a intentar otro tipo de
desplazamiento por aquí este carbono
azul tiene dos grupos met y los
podríamos ver qué pasa si hacemos un
desplazamiento con uno de estos grupos
metidos
entonces vamos a tomar este grupo de h3
y lo vamos a mover al carbono de acá
vamos a ver qué pasa si hacemos este
desplazamiento del grupo metilo
dibujamos nuestro anillo de carbonos uno
de estos grupos metilo se va a quedar en
este carbono azul pero el otro grupo
metilo fue desplazado a este carbono
entonces lo dibujamos por acá
este grupo metilo es este mismo grupo
metilo antes de que lo desplazaremos y
otra vez antes de que desplazaremos este
grupo metilo a este carbono este carbono
ya tenía un enlace con un hidrógeno pero
observa que en este desplazamiento le
estamos quitando un enlace a este
carbono azul entonces el carbono azul
ahora tiene una carga formal positiva y
entonces nos podemos poner a pensar qué
tipo de carbó cationes este y está
enlazado con 123 carbonos así es que es
un kart vocación terciario y sabemos que
los carbó cationes terciarios
estables que los secundarios entonces al
hacer este desplazamiento si estamos
aumentando la estabilidad de la molécula
este es el tipo de reacomodo que podemos
observar sucede un desplazamiento de un
grupo metilo para formar un kart
vocación terciario pero bueno también
podemos dibujar a esta molécula de una
forma más simple no dibujando todos los
hidrógenos y aquí tenemos estos dos
grupos metidos con una carga formal
positiva en este carbono